c'mon nation my name is Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all of the
week off from the world to help you in
your journey today we're going to talk
about how you can find water and as
always as I'm watching you hear
something that's readily refused please
leave it down down below look folks run
other because of the inspires like win a
prize - and ultimately write it down
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well
[Music]
if I said you can have any one thing you
can have good health
you can have money you can have the same
it allows you to inspire people what
would you choose is a one thing I
certainly I think without health you're
not around to do anything but I think
it's a life of meaning I don't think I
know it is feeling like your life
matters because you you have the
experience you and I both have lots of
friends you've achieved everything they
could ever dreamed of and they're
miserable I got a phone called up turn
them around they're missing a meaningful
life and meaning comes from two things I
always tell people happiness comes from
progress if you can do something where
you're growing and because you've grown
you have something to give to other
people that's meaningful insight love
caring something then life is rich
because happiness comes and goes
happiness does not here every moment and
the happiness isn't all it's cracked up
to day meaning is there are people that
have gone through horrible times but a
woman who was 109 years old and she was
you know when the concentration camps is
the oldest living Holocaust survivor and
that woman's life is so rich because of
all the pain because she's used that to
help other people fill 109 she's strong
you know she shares her music she does
the things that make her feel like she's
got a contributions whether or not she's
fully alive
who did you help I mean I really believe
that what life is truly about is making
other people happier and I know that
sounds very obvious but this does apply
to you as an entrepreneur or as a leader
as a high performer or as someone who
wants to play at world-class I mean I
really believe in this concept of
servant leadership and as I've studied
the great entrepreneurs and the great
business builders well the great
humanitarians here's what I've realized
inside sometimes it was very private on
the second point of the purpose of life
they had this acute obsession with
delivering value and helping as many
people as possible and I really do
believe that's the secondary purpose of
life it's helping others being radically
helpful to as many people as possible
here's the thing if you've done the
interior work so you are so full there's
no holes within you okay then you're not
going to be a taker from the world
you're going to be a giver and I'm going
to repeat that again if you look at the
greatest among us they were not takers
they were givers and here's why I think
they were givers they didn't have any
needs from within they had so fallen in
love with their greatness and their
peace and their joy and their potential
that they didn't need to take from the
world they didn't need to take from
other people they really were there well
of wisdom and compassion and self-worth
was so full that they walked out into
their workplace they walked out into
their industries they walked out in
their communities and they were giving
and this applies to you as a business
builder because the more value you give
the more money you'll make the more your
brand will fly the more customers will
beat a path to your doorstep and for you
in a humanitarian and you might not
think of yourself as a humanitarian but
a humanitarian is simply someone that
cares about humanity and as a
humanitarian the more you give the more
you will open up the doorways to receive
from the rest of the world if you live
in your kill you
final purpose to praise daily your life
did the day you were born and the day to
discover what and you're in a too old to
discover why see Kentucky Fried Chicken
you'll notice two picture of that man
Daryl their walk he'll take a picture
here within 20 that's a picture of him
when he hit the Kentucky curve with
frying this chicken of his life in a hit
he was 58 years old so like you children
focus you fit you 55 you don't know my
goggles justice trickle you but you
can't give up but you got to be doing
your gift stop with going to work land
without doing your gear if some of y'all
price hitting better buy some of y'all
baby pie some of y'all do have some of
you do makeup some of y'all work with
your any attorney offered prayer so we
all teach better some of you all network
better that's your gift go do that go
much would you try to work for every day
and you have to Joseph practice you got
bill you will have fields aren't you
what you do you don't even work for what
to commercial Fred I know you guys I
might know how that you know why we are
all unique we all share similarities you
know all human cultures across the span
of time has been found to truly value
very simple basic things you know love
truth fairness freedom unity respect
responsibility and tolerance and as we
recognize those now not all of them
exude it it great but as a part of their
culture they there was an operating norm
that value those types of things
something connects us it's a human
fabric of values and of beliefs that
usually center around caring and
compassion and love and truth with one
another because that's what keeps us all
together and that is what not only help
to survive at one point but more
importantly it made us feel spiritually
fulfilled
love is a purpose love has been argued
to be the purpose by a whole lot more
smart and intelligent persons than the
guy you're listening to right now I can
tell you that but if that's true if you
know
action love is so vital how are we doing
in those categories are we living
purposely with the people around us or
are we even sensing and seeing them so
that we can connect with them and live
out that purpose and sense that purpose
by really connecting with the people
that we truly love and adore a lot of
people are so distracted today they can
barely even look at some of the in the
eye when they walk down the street you
know they're looking like this
they can't even pay attention to their
spouse that or lover when they walk into
the house I mean they're distracted they
are detached and they are dissipating in
life energy because they are not giving
and receiving that incredible energy
that can only happen between two human
beings and so we have to ask how are we
doing and our relationships and could we
give more purpose to those relationships
so they can sense more purpose in life I
don't think you determine what your
purpose is I think you discover what
your purpose is there's a difference
determining indicates deciding and I
don't think you decide I think if you go
about it the right way you discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting all day
they're great artists I think
Michelangelo was obviously a great
artists great sculptor I mean that was
his purpose in his life well I believe
my purpose is doing what I'm doing your
purpose is why you get out of bed in the
morning do you know why you get up well
most people say well it's their go to
work well that'd be a good reason to
stay in bed you know you say well
everybody's doing it now it'll be
another reason to stay in bed if you're
ever doing what everybody's doing you're
probably going in the wrong direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down and
maybe take a pen and a pad and then ask
yourself what do I really love doing now
you may have to spend a while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning and go sit under a tree
somewhere if your
nice climate or pick a favorite chair
someplace where you're not going to be
disturbed and totally relaxed and say if
I could spend my life doing something
what do I really love doing now since
you don't ask yourself that question
every day it might take a while for this
answer to come to the surface but it
comes to your consciousness and I'm
going to take a while you may have to do
this every morning for three months but
it would be well invested the time what
lights you up in the morning you know
what would get you up early and keep you
up late
ask questions like if I could only spend
my life doing one thing what would it be
you know if if I had to actually pay to
do something as a job what would it be
and start getting in touch with that
part of you that then is compelled to do
things that align with your truth rather
than fits somebody else's pictures or
run after somebody else's dreams and
help them achieve their goals which
unfortunately most people do so once
you've found out what your passion is
the next step to deepen that is to get a
big enough why not a what why why is it
you're doing this because again if it's
to you know get approval if it's to get
significance if it's to be liked or
loved that's very shallow and very
short-term it's a hamster wheels are no
where for most people instead the people
who are the most passionate the people
that have the biggest why's usually
focus on something that is beyond
themselves you know do you have somebody
you love that you want to provide a
future for that you know you can share
together that comes from abundance not
scarcity do you want to be able to
provide opportunities for your children
that you never had do you want to create
a mark and leave a legacy in your
community or your country that most
people never be able to do and that
takes a level of commitment and courage
this service beyond our own ego you get
in touch with that part of you to dream
the truth that you were born to do and
be and I guarantee you passion will not
be far behind
you
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what do you think of this
video what did you take from it that
you're going to immediately apply seems
like forth to your business somehow
please share or leave it down in the
comments below I'm really excited to be
with you guys
I also want to give up insurance and
Brendon hook on to program is what other
person thank you so much Brandon or
figure have a copy of my book ear one
word and doing the review on your
YouTube channels
I really appreciate it I really
appreciate the point dude thank you so
much and less enjoyed this both does a
great job explaining why it's important
to discover your one word thank you guys
so much watching I believe in you know
to continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your wonder is much love have
an amazing day
so we talked about making your - dance
point one you got to be willing to do it
afraid so you might be waiting for the
fear to stop Lisa I heard that so much
I'm Lisa I'm afraid what do I do do it
anyway Lisa I'm afraid I don't quite
know if I should move move anyway I
don't know if I should leap leap afraid
and then gather your courage on the way
down and if you don't get it before you
hit you don't hit anyway I'd rather die
leaping than on the edge figuring out
how to get the courage to leap yes yes
yes yes
so many times we're waiting we're
waiting I'm waiting I'm waiting to get
something rise I see your hands going up
you guys know if it's your truth you can
raise your hand just like we did on day
zero you're just kind of waiting you're
waiting to get everything in order
you're waiting you're waiting so that
everything is is Inuits together you're
waiting to not be afraid you're waiting
to have the courage you're waiting to
have all the money you're waiting to
lose weight please see if I waited to
release my unwanted pounds before I got
in front of you Lisa Nichols would be
the secret yes yes I thought how about I
just leave with my imperfection and then
find my form of perfecting my
imperfection while I'm soaring how about
I do that how about I'm not how about
you not wait to get it right you look at
you figure out how does it look doing it
wrong how does that look because you're
80% of right is somebody else's hundred
and fifty nine percent of what they
needed yes yes and what you want to do
it right and you want to wait - you're
not afraid and you want to wait together
all together oh you made it about you
again see Nelson Mandela did it he just
did it not knowing if you were right
Mahatma Gandhi just did it not knowing
if it were right mother Teresa just did
it not looking for affirmation or
confirmation is this right
Martin Luther King did it not even
knowing if it would happen before his
life ended hey what are you waiting on
are you willing to do it afraid are you
willing to do it knowing that you got so
much work to do to get it better to get
it more perfect but are you willing to
do it inside your imperfection do you
realize it in your imperfection you're
perfect for the job who did you become I
mean did you use your days as platforms
for further greatness did you use your
days to transcend fear towards
fearlessness did you use your days even
the hard times so that you leveraged
suffering into wisdom did you use the
moments of your life to develop wisdom
compassion to become more creative to
release potential who did you become
that's really the first purpose of life
I believe